foreign
Salt Lake hi Dax what's up
hi Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
great so I'm 25 uh my wife is 21 and she
for the most part we've been able to you
know stay out of debt and do okay as far
as that goes but she's looking to go
into dental school and uh that's
expensive as I'm sure you know
and I'm just trying to figure out the
best way to uh just me and her how we
can if there's alternatives to going
into to you know getting student loans
and if not what's the best way to
approach that
um this sounds like she decided this
this morning
the way you described it not exactly she
started going to school for uh software
engineering
um and she hated it
um and uh this has been something we've
been thinking about for a few months now
yeah
I wouldn't do it I think it's BS how
much did you spend on the software
engineering
um so at that point her mom was able to
help her with that so there's no student
debt yeah no student debt right now
here's the thing okay she is not
completely sold out bought in on this
she's 21 years old and this is a 500 000
decision
and there's not a chance I'm doing this
not a chance
and certainly not going to go into debt
to do it because here's the deal let me
just tell you you go 500 000 in debt to
be a dentist 400 000 in debt to be a
dentist you're a dentist
even if you don't like it Tuffy wuffy
you're a dentist because you have to
clean this freaking mess up you don't
get to change your mind and decide you
hate it later because you just dug the
biggest freaking hole you can't even see
out of please don't do this
right yeah you're not gonna do it that
you're not gonna do it you don't want to
tell your wife no dude I'm telling you
please I'm begging you do not do this
if she wants to be a dentist let me tell
you how to do it this will end the whole
conversation join the military they'll
pay for it
mic drop
she's not doing that no no
she doesn't want it that bad nope uh she
might change her mind and not like it
yeah nope nope nope nope nope nope
someone who just changed their mind
after working on a degree for three
years because they hate it and three
months later wants to go five hundred
thousand dollars in debt if she told me
she wanted to be a dentist for the rest
for her whole entire life and you just
ran into her and you're part you're
grafting into the story of being a
dentist that's a different conversation
I'm not going to tell you to go into
debt to do it then but in this case I'm
gonna beg you do not do this not to
mention if she had paid for the
education of the software degree or if
she had to carry the debt from it no way
she'd be making that choice absolutely
absolutely please don't do this
but they're gonna do it yeah we'll do a
moment of silence for them right now
yeah